y
[Música]
[Aplausos]
se ha preguntado usted cómo sería
despertar después de haber hecho su
jornada matutina laboral tal vez después
de verse como para ser el perro haber
ido al gimnasio y de pronto amanece y no
tiene sus piernas
al hablar del tema de la discapacidad lo
primero que se nos viene es enfermedad
retraso mental llenos jóvenes a veces
esto se maneja mucho a manera de rechazo
nombre claramente hay todavía algunos
papás hermanos que tienen algún familiar
con discapacidad y los esconden no los
de cáncer no los dejan estar en sociedad
y por si fuera poco hay un grado de
ignorancia que puede llegar a contagiar
según esto la discapacidad les vengo a
hablar de todo esto es lo que es el
deporte tal como ha venido a cambiar mi
vida me ha hecho ser una persona más
madura una persona más responsable más
acerca a dios ya mi familia y sobre todo
ayudar a los demás es algo que siempre
me ha apasionado
el primero de diciembre del año 2010
recibí una invitación por parte de las
asociaciones de deportes para personas
con parálisis cerebral del estado vino a
cambiar radicalmente mi vida porque
limitaba a formar parte del cuerpo
técnico como entrenador de natación
está originando cambios positivos porque
yo estaba entrenando a personas
convencionales que están bien
físicamente
francisco cabrillo sandoval es un chavo
en cada conferencia que me invitan
siempre hablo leer es un joven atleta es
un profesionista él es doctor y me llena
de orgullo decirles es el médico de
nuestro equipo de la selección de
deportes para personas con pared
cerebral de natación
porque el creyente les habló de paz
bajó a los 8 años sufre un accidente
bajo estaba bien físicamente como tú
como yo como como los que hoy estamos
aquí
a los 8 años como todo el mundo
one rancho de su abuelo corrí entre la
misma y curando sin saber
desafortunadamente está aprendida lo que
es el aparato para captar la misma la
trituradora el cordel sin saberlo
y en esa desesperación él me cuenta de
cómo de pronto vio que en ese momento ya
no tenía piernas porque la cultura no
estaba funcionando cortando la hierba
él no tenía no quedar de las piernas de
la rodilla hacia abajo
así como lo escucho él perdió sus dos
piernas a los ocho años
ella el signo más adelante me cuenta
todo lo que sufrió para poder llegar a
donde estar
él tuvo que con sicólogos él sufrió
muchísimo por parte de sus compañeros de
escuela de clase como lo llevaban a ver
cómo lo aprendiendo y claro un niño al
ver una persona con discapacidad puede
es culpa de él sino que toda la
educación de unos recipientes de casas
de los papás los hermanos o los también
los maestros que estarán cargo al frente
de un grupo de niños hay que educarlos
hay que sensibilizarnos para poder
tratar este tipo de personas
el descuento también que está agradecido
con dios principalmente porque sin él no
hubiera seguido adelante el duro último
tiempo de trabajo es decir de equilibrio
a la escuela ya gerencia de ruedas dos
piernas cuando todos los compañeros de
la espalda lo veían él había pasado que
le habían hecho sino negro el día lo
tocaban pues para él a los ocho años
imagínense un tormentoso la ayuda de sus
papás o en algo primordial
para el seleccionado estatal y nacional
y orgullosamente después que yo lo
entrenó para que me ha ayudado no sólo a
mi equipo a motivar a los demás niños
sino a mí también cuando yo le pregunto
para ccoo y conmigo que estudiaba en ese
momento en ese que está estudiando la
carrera en la universidad autónoma del
estado la verdad me quedé impresionado
porque esta carrera implicada tus
prácticas implicados y social más
vitales él aún así no del poder de ir
entrenar para llegar a ser alguien en
cambio yo que soy licenciado en ciencias
del deporte mi carrera relativamente lo
acepto es más fácil me gusta el deporte
mucha práctica
entonces yo puedo pensar como una
persona
como paco terminó la carrera y medicina
es deportista cuando muchas veces
nosotros estamos bien físicamente
completos así decirlo nos ponemos los
mismos límites mentales
entonces hoy tengo claro de que verdad
querer es poder no poder los atracos no
siguiera adelante en pensar de que
podemos lograr muchas más cosas
otro caso que me tiene totalmente algún
que cambió muchísimo mi vida el de
ignacio martínez soto el ortubé el desde
más pequeño desde los 14 años y al
aprobarlo con muchísimo mi vida fue hace
5 años ya casi se cumple para ser
exactos fue el 7 de junio se pueden leer
el cumple
él me llamó y me dice por la mañana
apoyo tengo el mejor regalo que están
dado en la vida
y yo no te molestes no compres nada con
atenderte es más que suficiente no no no
yo la tarde el entrenamiento tener tu
regalo
ok entrenándose las iguala tarde y ya
media parece un acto de más de un
mensaje y me dice
8 llegando a la alberca espera
[Música]
i
el día del tratamiento
ya parte del 15 para 6 en stock
existente me dice aquí tenemos la marca
olímpica me dice 8 voltear de derecha y
yo estaba tomando tiempo estamos de más
deportistas concretas
sigo esperando estoy ocupado no gotea
no van a dejar mentir
nacho es un joven que nace con
discapacidad severa para ir celebrar los
doctores le dijeron que nunca iba a
poder caminar
en las terapias conmigo a este alto
rendimiento es un joven herido mundiales
panamericanos entonces siempre lleva con
sus días de ruedas
ya cuando volteaba nacho nacho iba
caminando con unos bastones y vas
haciendo eso iba caminando temblando y
gualda por la fuerza
yo los de 215 metros y corro sobre él y
que me dice moncho feliz
has aportado para poder caminar y ha
sido parte de mi vida fundamental cuando
el doctor me dijo que luego poder
caminar y las terapias de tumbes y las
heras
[Música]
ese día me llenó el mejor regalo que he
recibido en toda mi vida mis 30 años ni
un premio estatal del deporte ni una
medalla ya sé que son cosas
fundamentales que te hacen llenar como
personal pero te llena más rica que te
estás mejor poner por sus terapias una
calidad de vida impresionante el ahora
camina con bastones si va a ser que
termine sin algún aparato pero yo soy
diestro con dios con la vida por haberme
dejado
el compañero en sazón esas trayectorias
que como paso que nació bien físicamente
y perder tus piernas a los ocho años no
es nada fácil la verdad y como nacho que
nació con discapacidad
y que siempre tiene el apoyo de los
papás son personas en verdad son
guerreros son jóvenes con capaces
extraordinarias como yo lo llamo
aún me preocupa mucho el menosprecio
social gubernamental de dependencias
públicas como nosotros lo respetamos
unidad rampas y los estacionamientos no
hay las reposiciones en las escuelas
muchas veces nos rechazan por no saber
tratar un joven con discapacidad esto me
llena mucho de él de impotencia no puede
hacer nada hace un mes otro poder como
un carro de sitio servicio público no
llevó a un joven es que alrededor de
ruedas y olite porque mi hijo es que me
pone muchas trabas que no voy a hablarlo
cargando y que oye y no te ocasiona nada
más y valones sí que yo te acompaño y
aún así el software el joven le legó el
servicio no es justo que siga pasando
esto nuestra sociedad de verdad
hoy vengo a dejarles en claro que estos
jóvenes nos visitan ellos son parte de
aguascalientes parte de méxico son
nuevos profesionistas
son jóvenes que andan hablando del
deporte adaptado en lo que yo me realizo
tuve la oportunidad de ir al reale
alegro a los paralímpicos hace dos años
y me dijo que los primeros lugares no
saben todos los deportes estamos muy
bien son jóvenes que han dado la cara de
la casa por mexico no menos presión el
deporte convencional es que están bien
físicamente porque sé que todos a la vez
con muchas trabas en cuanto apoyos los
entrenamientos en la escuela en llevar
después de trabajo y el deporte es algo
muy difícil en méxico porque todavía no
hay ese apoyo y aparte agréguele le
ponen muchas trabas en cuanto a otros
estacionamientos las rampas de servicios
públicos
las becas entonces
y obtienen pedirles de favor que si
ustedes tienen un compañero al lado en
este momento un compañero en clases o su
primo o su hijo y de discapacidad por
favor
algunos de los si tienes la forma de
practicar una charla amena lo que sea en
verdad se lo decimos la experiencia que
vamos
van a mejorar para bien va a ser algo
muy enriquecedor a mí me pasó y
transformó mi vida como les dije al
principio soy una persona más madura una
persona más consciente responsable no me
gustaba el estudio y al nivel de tacto
al ver que si la medicina me motivó a
seguir adelante a seguir preparándome a
tomar cursos y más que nada porque por
esos chavos que no necesitan en verdad
ellos son parte de méxico de una
sociedad debemos ser más incluyentes
todos nosotros
por último quiero decirles quién tendrá
más discapacidad una persona que está
bien como tú como yo los estamos aquí
sentados que estamos completos que no
tenemos ninguna deficiencia o una
persona como papá que no tiene piernas o
como nacho que tiene espasticidad severa
díganme ahorita estamos bien pero mañana
quien sabe tal vez no le gustaría
ponerse en sus zapatos así que queremos
apoyar a méxico entonces vamos a hacer
delante ellos no necesitan muchísimas
gracias
[Aplausos]
[Música]